and in Somalia Security Forces say that
a deadly Siege at a hotel in the capital
of Mogadishu has come to an end
police and military say they managed to
rescue over a hundred hostages taken by
islamist militants after they stormed
the hotel on Friday evening it was a
popular meeting venue for politicians
and government officials the al-Qaeda
linked al-shabab group claimed
responsibility for the attack it was
their first major assaults in somalia's
new president took office in May
and let's get more on that attack now
from DW correspondent Felix Moringa in
Nairobi I feel it's good to see you can
you tell us first about the the victims
here we hear that families and children
were caught up in this standoff for
nearly 30 hours what more do you know
um yeah so the seeds that uh hadenka and
got Mogadishu ended around midnight last
night the police Commander has just
spoken this afternoon and he said that
they were able to rescue 106 people
including children and he said that a
father case on the specific injuries
will be announced by the medical
officers but he said that so far the
military had been able to shut down the
al-shabab and now the sieges is over but
something else it's not the first time
that the al-shabab is attacking a hotel
two years ago they also attacked a hotel
and 16 people were killed so it will be
interesting to see how president Mahmoud
deals with the al-shabab now that he's
back to the office right let's talk more
about that because this attack was the
first in the capital by al-shabab under
somalia's new government what does that
mean for stability and for their ability
to maintain stability
well uh it just lasted for about let's
say around 36 hours so the police were
able to actually come in uh flush out
the al-shababian sergeants and ensure
that everyone who had been held hostage
uh was actually rescued but what it
means to instability is that now the uh
just last month uh one of the former
al-shabab leaders was selected by the
prime minister in Somali to be in charge
of religion and a third cuts across also
so it will be interesting to see how the
two individuals both the Prime Minister
the president and the new recruit will
be able to deal with this insurgents and
also curtail their influence which has
been growing in the last few years
you know there are rumors about why
al-shabab attacked this hotel one being
that the hotel failed to pay extortion
money to the group is there anything
more you know about the possible
motivation of this attack
well the motive has not yet been
established it's not yet known why they
actually attacked this but this
particular Hotel hosts a dignitaries
hosts government officials and most of
the time even ministers from the
government also I go to this hotel so
this might have been part of the motive
but the motive is not yet known however
it is true that the al-shababin
sergeants have been taxing businesses
high-end businesses and several other
organizations for them to protect them
so rumor has it that the al-shabab has
been trying to ensure that whoever does
not comply with their rules is actually
they get to pay
heavily through attacks or something of
the Sun but we will wait to see what the
motive was but as as it stands The Siege
is over people have been rescued those
injured were rushed to hospital and we
shall be waiting for more information
from the police come commandant even as
the days go by all right Felix Moringa
there for us on the story in Nairobi
thanks very much
[Music]